bonjour je m'appelle Johanna je suis de
Saint-André je me suis installée en
auto-entrepreneur dans le domaine du
bien-être depuis le 3 juin 2013 je
propose donc des massages de bien-être
comme la réflexologie plantaire le
massage à l'huile le
massage d'oreille que les gens aiment
beaucoup parce que c'est proposer dans
pas beaucoup d'endroits et le massage
ama assis en soins énergétique je
propose le soir Reiki et le soir
allégorie et je propose aussi de
l'hypnose ericksonienne en séance
individuelle et en atelier auto-hypnose
mon projet serait de m'installer dans un
plus grand local pour pouvoir faire
travailler pour pouvoir travailler avec
d'autres personnes dans le domaine du
bien-être toujours comme par exemple un
coach chanson sportif une ongle une
prothésiste ongulaire enfin bon tout ce
qui touche au bien-être ma différence
c'est peut-être mes prix qui sont qui
font partie des plus bas du marché pour
qu'un plus large public puisse accéder à
ce genre de service qui reste quand même
luxueux à mes yeux